good morning John so I've been thinking
a lot in you know that's trouble I've
been thinking things like if no cows can
dance then can some cows want to dance
and can a person ever really be free
from their upbringing and why is it so
easy and in some ways so rewarding to
play video games and if the citizens of
Ally want their children to be educated
today but that may mean that they will
all die in a year's time could I ignore
their needs now in order to protect them
in the future and if I do that then am I
really being evil what do you think
would happen if the giraffe loved shirt
weer on sale at like Target or Hot Topic
but a bunch of non nerdfighters be
wearing it and what the heck am I gonna
be for Halloween and if mr. Schuester
was going to be Rocky and Rachel was
going to be Janet then how would the
touch a touch me number really have gone
seems like a pretty gaming potholed mr.
Schuester was like I'll be Rocky and
used 16 year old girl you can be Janet
and would I be a different person if I
didn't ask so many questions and what
does it mean that social structures
among young people are so often
predicated upon trying really really
hard to appear to not be trying and what
is the world going to be like in 20
years more importantly what are the
vlogbrothers going to be like in 20
years
worst case scenario Jon you are writing
vampire novels and I'm in Vegas every
afternoon playing a lounge show at
Caesar's Palace 30 minutes off the strip
singing to five people in the audience
who have no idea who I am a walk is a
fundamental constituent of matter hey
thanks for coming out observed in 1968
through deep electrics getup Pesce
scenario looks it looks a lot like this
we're making videos that are
informational and educational and
entertaining
let's do for that also going back to my
earlier questions I just got fable 3
which for those of you who don't know is
an action-adventure role-playing video
game thing and just before I went and
got people three I asked nerdfighteria
on Facebook and on Twitter I said I am
seriously considering going to buy HIPAA
three should I do that despite the fact
that I probably will then spend the next
three weeks of my life untidy and
unproductive and unloved and unwashed
and the overwhelming response was yes
yes Hank of course yes do it do it do it
dodo dodo do it and I'm confused about
that I thought that you people wanted me
to make entertaining videos and write
funny songs and just you're wildly at
the camera and I can't do that if I'm
trying to say the citizens of Albion
from some oily black menace so
why not that if you didn't want me to I
wouldn't have bought it of course I
would have one thing is that being nerdy
is important to my job if you consider
this my job and nerds have to play video
games it's a law of nature
but I'm curious about the lore of video
games and what makes them so
spectacularly interesting and awesome
and we all know the video games are a
simplification of real life but I think
that's what's so compelling about them
because real life is complicated video
games give us goals and you know when
you failed and when you succeeded in
real life that's pretty rare especially
as you get older everything you do is a
combination of success and failure there
is no absolute success and failure there
is no moment which you complete the
mission and say ah I am done thank you
because the mission is never complete
because the mission is your life and it
only completes when you die so what I'm
playing video games it is intensely
comforting but that doesn't mean that
there's something really remarkable and
awesome about the ambiguity of real life
it is not as comfortable and soothing
and relaxing also this is the last day
that you could pre-order the draft love
shirt it's officially the best-selling
shirt in dftba records history and I'd
be lying if I said that I wasn't proud
that my design currently holds that
title all they want to do is love each
other for a very short and terrifying
amount of time before the dude runs off
in shags a bunch of dudes that's for
what I'm going to be for Halloween I am
sorry I am NOT going to be Rocky
I am NOT going to be dr. Frank I'm not
even going to be Phineas Gage which I
thought about trying to do for a long
time but but gave up on if there are any
nerdfighters who are gonna be Phineas
Gage I want pictures I am going as
dexter nerdfighters in the comments
please let me know what you thought of
Glee and what you are going to be for
Halloween and if you don't I won't kill
you unless I suspect that you are a
murderer and that you're going to kill
more people in the future John I will
see you on Wednesday